Jamie we supreme is back with minecraft
minecraft' how many episodes until I
become an official minecraft channel now
some new things has happened do you
remember that vendor that I was like
should I kill him and everyone said yes
but I didn't do it
well I killed him and now he's Lamas
well they finally stop spitting at me
all thank God they kept spitting at me
oh we're friends now that's awesome so I
have their leashes wish I can use some
Jurgen what I bought cow
oh I'm riding llama Oh
oh yeah minecraft this is awesome okay
oh there's another thing I want to do
okay so look at this gamers I was like I
was like oh yeah my storage it's getting
a little cramped so I make epic storage
that's right gamers now I have plenty of
space to store all my dirt I also have
lava dispenser which I can just toast
bad things into this is very respectable
it just takes me a while to find what is
I need to find all right don't worry
about it ah here it is nametag so a lot
of you been saying that I can put a name
tag on Jurgen and I'm like that's epic
Jurgen how I put name tag on you take it
it's a friend you're again
don't make me here no sorry
quick yeah again he must heal he must
heal
eat it you need to eat something you're
gonna die stop spitting oh I need an
anvil and ville can I can't make an
anvil how I make anvil ayran ingot lock
of iron
none e12 oh these are so pretty
d okay so it's like this alright look at
this gamer and Ville baby
smash like if you're a gamer and you
knew how to make a anvil from head what
BAM it's nametag time bros okay this
alright
we should be called your again
enchantment cause what how do I get a J
with what what I did it Jurgen you're
gonna have a name this is historical
moment away it was supposed to be
chairing in the second god damnit what
is enchantment cost what am I paying my
soul here you go yet again you're again
the second yeah eat some weak alright so
surely oh wow llamas earth yo you're so
close no way did we not love each other
I think this situation is getting a
little out of hand
guys please one at a time one at a time
I'm so generous look at these it's
Christ it your again stop it now I know
for a fact that your guineas are gonna
run anywhere that's amazing and yet
again you look yet friend
you say another word to me and it's the
ax okay cool so today we're gonna do
epic adventure we're gonna go through
nether portal
okay gamers its portal time what are you
doing here oh god I almost choked on G
fuel that was crazy
okay let's go gamers Jesus Christ ade
whoever said minecraft it wasn't scary
told a lie all right I gotta be careful
here because the ghost lady thing blew
up my branch
my poor bridge didn't do anything look
at that look at this dude very epic
let's go through gamers wait
Pigman went through Pigman coca can't go
back home Pigman you had to go back home
you're lost and confused don't worry
I'll help you what if I kill him in this
world then I can get his epic diamond
sword big man big man stop big man stop
you're gonna get yourself killed big man
Please Please big man big man damnit oh
oh yeah we're going to the city because
I need to trade wheat because if I trade
with I get the pearls and I like purpose
I don't know what to do with them
a bunny just died oh my god it's being
invaded ah what is this
kill the small ones kill younglings guys
this is not epic there's a zombie
invasion what la face this is not my
battle
this is not my fight no getting
dangerous eat what is that a wizard this
is two epic gamers that's gamer
intuition what to do with the right
don't worry
I saved your city now trade me wheat yes
doing yeah what are you doing with that
el wizard it's time to god damn it I
lost the wizard where the Wiz ago I
killed wizard he still be here I look
away one second he's still here swear I
swear I can't play two minutes of this
game without getting distracted what was
i doing look there enchanted arrows I
knew it was wizardry is he the one that
attacked the village
trade me wheat sir
no nut paper there it is there's only
one emerald fine
that's pretty more thank you thank you
for your business look we got that bling
we got that emerald he trade me for
wheat what a weed you know I say oh we
can trade these for bricks that's
amazing I don't understand what's
happening here
that's just all I'm saying no
discrimination like they can be what you
look like such a pimp you just sell me
paper you do I look like I need paper
you look like you're stone out of your
goddamn mind
oh I get it
oh I guess you think they give you a
thanks for saving this city but no
minecraft heroes do exist
never take one for granted all right
there's a new area I want to explore
let's get a gamer's whoa there's oh god
there's mountains up in the distance
okay this could be a good place to set
up camp
one two okay we set up a new camp gamers
this is epic
very good second house be quiet but
that's not why we're here
we're here to explore new adventures and
lands while you were out meeting new
people I was mining fluxing minecraft
discovering new words looking at new
places what is that a boat it's Titanic
we found it
what is all this it's icebergs it's
freakin icebergs in Minecraft
what can I my knees do they explode it's
ice what if we found Titanic what would
you do what what is that what is that
that is awesome I'm being like ironic
about it but it looks so cool this is so
awesome
what there's bears how can there be
bears hello beer
konnichi what man Mesa no come inside do
you want you can I give you you want
this you want some bone fine leave then
see if I care
there's Titanic I freaking found a tech
gamers gamers oh my god we gotta find it
an airlock or else this is not gonna
last very long I really so people said I
can make a potion to breathe on the
water go down god damn it
where's the chest oops
I read them [ __ ]
don't need them yeah what's in the books
separate books chest number two okay oh
okay okay
we're okay let's not be greedy now we
got another treasure map brush oh we're
actually not that far should we maybe
later maybe later got plenty of places
to go like this is this is this just
like a mountain it's not special at all
just looks like an eagle castle isn't it
that's another boat are you kidding me
and I like you to find too many things
minecraft minecraft' there's so many
things to explore again Timmy look at
that look at that it's all coming out of
the mountain you [ __ ] get it what I
got damn I hate them all right so let's
build a tower here so that we can find
our way back to uragan later because if
we can't make it back to your gandi then
what's the point
and also okay they're made a gem Jesus
Christ I'm scared oh God
[Applause]
Oh today just on erotically say you okay
there's clearly something down here
all will be there's something over there
my bow my boss what is hat that's my
book
oh they're going together that's so cute
okay you guys are cool you guys control
with me I so like that this is just an
airlock oh it is
alright guys loke need the boat back can
you please can I make a new boat I have
enough material guys I need the boat I
need the freakin boat oh my god hey we
can be friends we can ride boat together
oh it isn't underwater city oh wow ok so
some of you told me that these magma
blocks you can step on them to replenish
your air which is not working oh it is
working this makes no sense minecraft
just
Golden Apple baby brick yeah if we got
break over here oh I'll grab some break
another chest I can't open it how out
it's just wheat gamers god damn it that
is so cool
such a giant waterfall dude look at that
tree dude we don't get treats like that
at home oh my god the map is filling in
fine we'll do one more for this time
I'll find that god damn all I'm saying
is the loot better be epic okay here we
go
hopefully it's not under water this time
oh god it is alright x marks the spot
oh my god I found it right away oh my
god can't believe it
what why'd it take me so long last time
oh god I am way too slow dude we got
diamonds I don't care if I'm choking no
Oh God huh no you're good what no I have
to head back
among this item stay oh god where was a
where was that oh god I don't remember
wait I can review the footage oh my god
I am such an idiot I'm retracing my
steps oh god the Sun is setting such a
beautiful sunset
okay oh my god I found him oh it's all
floating I'll dude there's a wizard and
Enderman oh god don't look at his eyes
look we got heart of the sea I think
this is like an actual rare item there's
another floating treasure map no big
deal
I think I'm stuck you guys told me I
need to kill these guys so I'm just
gonna do it I'm sorry I'm sorry this is
not personal I think you're cool if I
had to pick then we would chill and eat
melon and be epic Oh what if I blow him
up alright see you in a bit so gamer
gamer Adam did he drop item that was
epic man this place is so much cooler I
feel like I should emigrate here with
Jerry again he would like the trees and
the ice mountain's whoa what is that
whoa he's got a freaking trident dude
I'm under attack gamers oh my god you
dropped the gold
this guy's a rich no are you kidding me
stop Felix stop stop what you're doing
you idiot oh god damn it I'm going to
sleep and when I wake up how could I get
my back
[Applause]
stop being so greedy Felix God Danny why
here we go again was it here it was here
wasn't it oh my god there he is
Oh God okay oh yeah gamer I'll get him I
wasn't such a klutz you know at least he
didn't steal my stuff I appreciate that
where's the gold where's the diamond
gold oh it begins dude he does so much
damage alright so the plan is to let him
shoot his friend there you go and then
we swim towards him you can't do this
forever
he dropped it that's a super rare drop
[Music]
get it I got it right at you yeah I
gotta try it alright I gotta try it it
can I shoot that's awesome just wait
until you hear again seize this oh my
god he's gonna flip out
alright I'm going home that's enough
Felix you're going straight home two
pancakes pancakes I've actually become a
infantilized by this game damn it feels
good to come back with this much epic
loot today all gamers get spread damage
when that wall diamonds when I talk yeah
that was when I bought oh I can make a
conduit with heart of the sea I'm going
to sleep
dude I'm getting pro at minecraft I'm
finding so many stuffs whoa whoa bubble
boom hold on hold on I'm rich
that's more money than I traded from
wheat in a year supply that I didn't win
the lottery thirteen what and then you
get potatoes and paper aqua infinity
this is I mean I can breathe on the
water better
let's try oh it does seem like the
bubbles are different no way there's no
difference I'm an idiot all right let's
get the second treasure man because the
loot was too good I can't ignore oh my
god there's another one this one is all
blown up dude found it right away gamers
and it's potato and carrot stew 2 9
gamers what a poor [ __ ]
this is IKEA [ __ ] huh
goddamn this one is far away I'm gonna
have to dude look at that
minecraft was not this epic when I
played it okay you would not see stuff
like that so sorry if I am super amazed
there there's a dog thing oh my god hey
dog I love you
come back I give more steak you want
more steak how about you like potatoes
you want potato carrot
[Music]
okay it's cool maybe bonus Oh another
one
want another one keeps looking at me
you're so cute I've given you everything
I have don't look at me like that
I'm cooking chicken for this dog
it's the chicken done know what about
chicken you like chicken he likes
chicken
now go in there go in might go on didn't
know I don't that's all I have
don't leave me I love you
I don't have anything eggs mate it's not
abuse it's not abuse damn it daddy's
coming home very soon just need to what
am i doing I'll leave him with Apple and
water okay
it'll be fine be right
I'll be right no no not today mr.
creeper God I need to start making match
I just need to follow these bones
I heard bones over here and I need them
I've never been so glad to see this guy
no he's got a caller does that mean
you're my friend
what let's go gamer I need to bring you
back home your again it's gonna see you
we can shake it's so cute
what other commands does he know good
how do i command the dog like go fetch
we just follow me Oh more bones Oh God
oh my god I see you attacking go doggy
get him he's running away you're not so
tough now are ya he likes the bones here
have a bone he needs a name Sven and
Sven is on the attack let's go gamer did
you hear that Sven I think we're getting
close to the treasure but my cod were
far away from home all right just
cool Sven can teleport that's good to
know Oh we're filling in the map oh my
god diamonds and heart of the sea again
goddamn we're on a roll today we got
Sven we got all these epic stuff
we got it let's bounce gamer okay now we
just gotta find our way home oh my god
with swim swimming it might take a while
I think someone has earned a little
snack Sven that's right I love you too
we're gonna have to stay the night in
here spend it's okay it's cozy I know
you're scared of dark I lit up for you
look he's got his little spine that's so
cute since I'm such a child yeah it was
a good dog
whoo that's right useful I've been
playing it for two hours and I still
have so much to do all right that's
enough
let's go gamer god it's a creeper let me
take care of it don't hurt my dog can I
give a shield to Sven oh god what if we
if we don't make it back do I start a
new home with Sven but what about your
game well there's a house here what I
was looking for my boat
let's get real we're never gonna make
you back home there's too many
distractions what is this dude this
looks so cool it's more villagers
good talk
oh he take
he actually trades rotten flesh I have
so much of it I saved it for no reason
it's a cat wearing armor does that mean
you can wear armor pen
hello no he was here a second no I can't
do this I cannot have another pet that
act like this oh my god there he is
I can't but you got a swing dude oh my
god are you actually this slow
look he teleports oh my god is this time
we're gonna have to do it spent there
you go oh my god this is gonna take so
long but it will be worth it god damn it
oh my god it's a sea turtle
it has stranded itself don't worry sleep
better life save your life wow I see
there you go you're back with nature and
your mom friend thing
live live god dammit I have to sit
through the night again because this guy
can't swim what we walk back to this
house so that's where the compass said
you're again you're good there's someone
I want you to meet here again burn smell
good and the boat cow and the llama guys
my and and water sheep okay this is epic
yay oh boy did we get some epic
here again the adventures I can tell you
about all right this definitely does it
for this episode
damn what you never played super
simulator you know it's fun right I'm
not supposed to give my opinion but give
it a try and then you can tell me if
it's good or not not convinced yet okay
I'll cut you a deal the game is
available for free and that's a great
price
[Music]